[Music]
uh for those of us that are not pet
stewards how do we appropriately address
our loved ones who are pet stewards who
constantly dump the burden of
obligations and responsibilities of pet
stewardship onto others
that is
how do we respectfully remind them that
pet stewardship is not just the pleasure
of companionship for them to enjoy
but also the pain of daily maintenance
for them to bear now don't we see this
all the time where of course the kid
wants to bring a dog home because it's
so cute and cuddly and i'll love it i
promise i'll clean up after it all feed
it i'll do everything and then four days
later four weeks later four months later
it's like
yeah it's a fixture in the house and i
do enjoy petting it but i don't want to
take care of it really and we don't
think about all the resources it takes
besides money it takes time and
attention and energy not to mention that
a dog is you basically have a two to
three year old toddler the entire life
that's the phase that they are in they
have to be maintained
and that two to three year old i mean
they're very high maintenance their
whole life
so while we may fall in love with the
concept of becoming a best friend to an
animal we may not think through the time
and energy and emotional commitment
financial resources that it takes to
give that animal the quality of life
that it needs and deserves for its
entire lifespan
so
as a proactive wellness veterinarian i
have to say that pre-purchase or
pre-adoption counseling is like the most
important thing for marital relations
for household peace
that adopting an animal
cannot be
a whim it has to be the same level and
weight as adopting a child in the sense
that you would plan about it you would
talk about it do you have the resources
do you have the time available who
exactly will be caring for the animal
for the next 15 years who exactly will
be walking the animal and if you haven't
seen
the level of commitment and
responsibility be role modeled in your
spouse or your mate or your kids yet
then i would say don't get a german
shepherd puppy because you haven't yet
had the relationship dynamic unfold with
a child or a spouse enough for you to
know you know what i feel like this
could all end up on me and if you're
cool with that ending up on you yeah
awesome if you're not cool then first
and foremost i would say preemptively
before you get before you bring life
into your home
and then have that life be stressful or
a source of family conflict
you've got to make sure that the entire
family recognizes the rules and
responsibility of the weight of what it
takes to responsibly care for that
animal for the duration of its life
if you come into a relationship and your
wife your girlfriend has a puppy or your
boyfriend has a dog or a cat and now you
are marrying into that there again you
would want before you
decide to take that on you would want to
say hey listen if we're going to spend
our life together are you going to
continue caring for this animal you know
whose responsibility will this be yeah
yeah we were talking about that before
we started recording it when i met my
wife uh our daughter was one year old
she's my stepdaughter i treat her like
she's my daughter but
you have to be all the way in with that
too if you start dating someone you're
going to move in together but i hate
dogs
well you're going to be miserable or
you're going to have to find a way to
stop hating dogs right that's right so
when i met mariah she had a cat
and we were looking for an apartment to
move in together and let me tell you
when you have a cat it cuts out like 50
to 60 percent of the available
apartments so there were some like
really nice places where i'm like like
you know good location yada yada no pets
and so i i go to mariah my my now wife
i'm like
is there any way we could just like
maybe find this cat another home or and
she's like no she's like this is
this is the whole package and i tried
the same thing with ella can we just
and you know uh but but you know it was
a very um it wasn't something that i let
you know bother me it was like she just
kind of helped me see like oh this is
part of the package so i was like
totally willing to accept that and now i
would i would like never get rid of this
cat like i i am now bonded to this cat
so uh yeah i totally agree it's like
it's it's it's a whole package type deal
for sure but you have a weird sort of
situation here and alabama can can
testify to this because she will catch
it for you from time to time but your
cat mac yes i've known you for 30 years
i've seen mac twice ever right
you go to the house he wants to be in
the same room with you but he doesn't
want you to make eye contact or um he's
a barn cat
he's like he's yeah he's feral he's like
very
standoffish um independent independent
yeah yes yes
and he has he i mean he's come from
generations of barn cats
so there is like a little feral aspect
even when like when you hear something
the way his ears perk up i'm like oh
that looks like a bobcat which like most
cats you know like like domesticated
they they're floppy and yeah so he's
tame but i don't think he's so
domesticated per se but what i did so
yeah
you could to become mac's friend
just like with any animal you give it
food there you go so mac was uh he was a
pretty fit young strapping cat when uh
he first entered my life
um about two or three years into it he
gained a little bit of weight
um mainly because i was like feeding him
uh like we give him cat food but then i
would give him like just little bits of
like lunch meat ham or turkey which like
you know he absolutely loves so um it
totally worked like him and i are now
bonded but i have stopped since like
feeding him
lunch meat like because my i mean and
and you inten correct you shouldn't be
lunch videos yeah right yeah
thank you so much so yeah my wife she
was trying to explain to me she's like
look when you give and correct me if i'm
wrong or if she's wrong when you give a
cat like a little piece of meat like for
them it's actually like kind of a bigger
thing because of you know how small they
are um and not to mention yeah the salt
and the all the processed stuff
yeah yes i mean that's that's just an
awesome question and and that's you know
i mean i'm guilty of it too right behind
my love right i think that's how
relationships start between boyfriends
and girlfriends right to start taking
you know your girlfriend to like
beautiful restaurants and and you bond
over food i mean food is like one of the
most incredible bonding experiences in
the world and yeah too i'm guilty of it
and especially in the pet space you
always want to
you feed with love right especially
coming from a mediterranean family my
god like you know we were always like if
you didn't finish your place you were
beaten so you were
and you fed with love right you just
always gotta keep handing out treats and
so on and so forth you know we were
really
when it's especially when it comes to
cats right um
the type of food
i don't i personally don't think there's
anything wrong with that bond sharing
food i know sometimes you got trainers
that say you know don't feed them at the
table and they can develop terrible sort
of um
begging at the table and so on and so
forth so i mean look
putting that aside um
it's kind of like the perception of food
like what am i sharing with my pet and
ultimately there's things that i can
pull out of my refrigerator to share
with my pet that's going to benefit me
and benefit my pet overall
um lunch meats
delicious right in italy they're like
they're prepared differently in italy
than they are right he like perks up so
quick when he sees it
right so i guess it's really going to
depend on sort of like the lunch meat
itself because of course we know that
you know some of these meats can have
like sodium nitrate and the world health
organization steps in and says you know
eating that stuff can increase your rate
of cancer and so on and so forth and
because they're so small like they're
the load of sodium nitrate that you
would be taking in versus your cat would
be taken it would be exponential so
there'd be nothing wrong if i was
sharing let's say an organic piece of
like chicken like um or like free range
beef or something like that with my pet
so that's important because one of the
challenges that we know is that not only
do pets do they mimic mimic us like when
it comes to stresses and so on and so
forth but they also mimic our disease
rates so you know i know that there's
like an obesity rate right now globally
right it doesn't matter where it is and
um and don't quote me on the statistics
in america but i believe the last time i
saw the human obesity rate was you know
an overweight was like around 50 it
holds true with cats and dogs they
mirror us right and when we eat we
typically we feed our pets and i know
multiple studies have come out to say
that overweight and not in anyone else
not
not a lot of people that are listening
because they don't get offended with me
but research shows that a lot of
overweight pets come from overweight
families right because it's that stop
point right and then what is the
perception of food that we're seeing
because to some people
sharing table scraps this is kind of
this is kind of what was our biggest
hurdle in writing the book that term
table scraps right it was a term that
was like developed in like 1890 where
the invention of the first sort of ultra
processed food where some genius named
james spratt from america was like hey
man maybe i can make like pet food and i
can make this very convenient but how do
i get people to stop feeding foods well
let's vilify the term table scraps
because what on earth were people
feeding before 1890 to their pets like
what have people real lifestyle right
real food right and we would use a
pejorative like table scraps that's
right to ruin that real fast 100 and so
and that still holds true today you walk
into your veterinarian like hey man
watch out on those table scraps my
friend right because what is the
definition of table scraps it's never
been clarified every home is different
maybe i see do sometimes giving their
dogs a little bit of beer and wine and
stuff like i mean it's
it's like what are you doing right or
getting cats to like eating nachos and
stuff like that so
there are those people like those
caveats you know what i mean like those
rabbits have to be there on what you're
sharing what are those table scraps but
if if the food is healthy if the food is
what you would feed your children it
would you'd feed an infant a
one-year-old and you'd feel comfortable
with
i believe those are the type of foods
that you should be sharing with your pet
yeah and and animals most of them go
through life never getting any fresh
food so the fact that we can open up our
fridge and share fresh foods with our
dogs and cats it's the it's the only
time that they get foods that contain
enzymes and that have not been
adulterated and that and that still have
nutrients and polyphenols and
antioxidants included
so sharing
what i call biologically appropriate
treats with your cat is fantastic but we
also have to think about why and when we
treat animals oftentimes you know we're
working 10 hour days we're stressed out
we haven't given the time and attention
to our pets so you know what we do we've
we treat them instead of spending time
with them instead of being present and
focusing
yeah it's like here just eat yeah eat
you're just keep having
yeah yeah so snacks emotional emotional
bonding can't be done with just over
feeding your pet we end up with a lot of
fat diabetic cats and we end up with a
lot of kidneys with kidney disease and
organ disease and we we don't
necessarily we're not nourishing them
the way nature intended so kitties and
dogs actually don't have a carbohydrate
requirement they don't need any carbs to
be healthy oh wow and yeah the average
baby don't don't eat plants at all and
unless they're in like strange
starvation situation and even then they
don't have the digestive tract to really
yeah they'll nibble grasses of course
yeah and they rely on getting the plant
material inside of their appraised gi
tract that's passed at the food chain
those pre-digested prebiotic fibers that
come from their appraised gi tract like
if you really had a barn cat barn
kitties hunt mice regularly and they eat
the whole darn mouse you know they're
not cooking it they're not removing the
bone in the skin they're eating the
whole mouse and that's they're eating
the mouse microbiome they're eating all
the mouse organs they're eating
everything and that fresh whole life
package meal contains everything that
nature intended for him to be thriving
in in in a metabolic machinery state
that allows him to live a long healthy
life the problem is cat food
doesn't have the same macronutrients did
you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free